most of us
are familiar with the term genie it's a
pretty simple concept
you find a magical lamp you rub
said lamp and then a weird cryptic
spirit comes out and tells you they will
grant you
three wishes sounds too good to be true
and that's because it is most of the
time you'll either end up dead or in a
worse situation than before
modern-day genie can be rather unhelpful
and outright strange characters but even
they pale in comparison to the original
stories and legends
the westernized term genie comes from
the arabic word
jinn ancient spirits and demons who
bring a whole new meaning to the phrase
be careful what you wish for
today's video has been made possible by
audible
i enjoy reading as much as the next
person but most of the time i just want
to sit back relax and have someone else
immerse me in a story which i imagine is
why many of you
watch and listen to this channel audible
gives me the flexibility to pop in my
earphones and listen to whatever i want
wherever i am with audible plus you have
thousands of titles to choose
from audio books to podcasts comedy
shows
and tons of amazon originals a
membership to audible plus
gives you access to any title in the
audible catalog
with no limitation you can download the
audible app on all smartphones and
tablets
and listen to your favorite titles
offline wherever you are at any time
i'm a big fan of stephen fry's greek
myth series and i recently finished
listening to the latest edition
troy which is a fascinating listen for
anyone interested in greek mythology
for those who don't know fellow youtuber
legends of history
and myself published a book last year
titled greek mythology explained
it's also available on audible for you
to listen to
now is the best time of the year to join
audible with their special holiday offer
your first 6 months will only cost you
4.95
a month as opposed to the regular price
of 7.95
you can join today by visiting
audible.com
mythology and fiction that's audible.com
mythology and fiction or you can text
mythology and fiction to 500
500 so don't miss out download audible
today
legends of jinn are most commonly
associated with islamic myth
and stories even older in the arabian
peninsula
however entities similar to the jinn
appear all throughout the world
in islamic tradition the term jinn is
used as a collective to refer
to any group of supernatural creatures
it can also be used to refer to a
specific creature
for example you may have a piece of work
about
a gin or you may have a group of
miscellaneous demons and spirits that
are referred to
as jinn or jinn communities
like demons they can be evil but in some
stories jinn are benevolent they are
summoned and bound by a sorcerer
not too different from the stories of
genie
before islamic belief a group of middle
eastern scholars described the jinn
as evil spirits who reside in the desert
and
unclean places they would disguise
themselves to pass us by
as animals others believe the jinn were
closer to deities
and as a result they were worshiped when
islam became the religion of choice
these deities may have been
perceived as having pagan influences
and thus they played a much smaller role
in everyday life
despite once being seen as deities they
were never considered
immortal or invincible there are notions
of
armed men being able to kill a jinn they
are however
mostly just theories as jin could not
only
shapeshift but also turn invisible so
good luck trying to kill something you
can't even see
jin will also consider the spreaders of
disease and mental
illness they could possess one's mind
and body
as we move into scripture the overall
stature of the jinn
changes in the story of solomon jyn were
spirits of nature
similar to the previous pagan deities
solomon was gifted the power to talk to
animals and spirits
and thus he was able to reign in the
unruly jinn
and command them to help build the first
temple in ancient jerusalem
in the quran itself the jinnah mentioned
a grand total of
29 times most of this occurs in the 72nd
chapter titled al-jin or
the jinn in order to maintain the notion
of there being only one
true god the jinn shift from deities to
lesser spirits who in terms of hierarchy
in relation to god
are roughly level with humans meaning
they are subject to his judgment in
death
they exist somewhere in between our
realm and the spectral realm
in one hadith the jinn are divided into
three distinct
groups jin who fly through the air
jin who could take the shape of dogs and
snakes
and jinn who travel in the same way as
humans
scholars have interpreted the quran's
use of jinn to mean
one of two things an entity or being
that exists
in a plane invisible to humans therefore
we can categorize
angels and demons as jinn but not every
jinn
is an angel or demon you then have a
description that paints them in a light
similar to humans jinn were created from
a smokeless fire
and inhabited the earth before adam and
the first
humans they were faster and stronger
but they still lived like humans in many
ways
they still had to eat sleep and drink
and when they died they would be sent to
heaven or
hell depending on their actions they
were also divided into separate tribes
with each one being created from a
different mixture of fire wars between
light and dark angelic and demonic gin
occurred quite often it even became
common to
explain violent storms as warring tribes
of jinn
invisible to the human eye these storms
represented the chaos and aftermath of
these battles
this conflict can also be explained by
taking a look at another traditional
story
which tells us why the jinn may have
disappeared
the angels were created on wednesday the
gin on a thursday and a thousand years
later
humans on a friday these three races
co-existed peacefully
until corruption violence and greed
overcame the jinn
the warnings of god were ignored and he
was given no choice but to send the
angels to purge the jinn
most of them subsequently died and the
few gin that did survive were exiled
from
earth these traditions involving jinns
spread across
more than just arabia reaching turkey
north africa and even the balkans in
morocco
exorcisms were performed for those who
were thought to be possessed by aegin
however they couldn't just possess
anyone they would
target people whom they considered
vulnerable
often referred to as a tired soul
someone who was unhappy mentally
unstable
or just depressed hence the association
with jin
and mental illness another widespread
belief is that the jinn live underground
where they plot and scheme against
humanity
they surface only to spread illness and
cause
harm to those who mistreat others this
extends to possession and kidnapping
children
in this case the jinn exists as a moral
lesson
or reminder
so how did we go from jinn to genie
the most obvious example being the genie
in disney's aladdin
who is far from an evil spirit this and
many other tales are inspired by the
arabic
text 1001 nights a collection of middle
eastern folk tales from the 8th to the
14th century
for many of these tales their source of
origin is unknown
but there are numerous influences from
arabic
persian and greek to indian turkish and
chinese
so it's an amalgamation of cultures from
basically everywhere
in english it's also commonly referred
to as the arabian nights
here the jin make an appearance in a
number of different stories
the most noticeable being aladdin and
the wonderful lamp
in this story aladdin isn't too
different from the disney variation
a young mischievous misguided lad who is
found in the streets of a chinese city
by a
sorcerer who claims to be the brother of
aladdin's father
so his long lost uncle and no before you
ask
this man is not called jafar he claims
to be
mustafa the tailor he convinces aladdin
and his mother that he only wants to
help them
but first he needs a favor of course
inside of a cave there is the most
wonderful oil lamp in all the land if
aladdin is able to retrieve it he
promises
they will never be poor again the cave
however is magically booby-trapped and
dangerous enough that mustafa himself
would never dare to enter
but he does give aladdin a magical ring
for protection
once inside her no one's surprise
mustafa double crosses aladdin
and leaves him trapped inside the cave
in despair of his situation
aladdin begins to rub his hands in doing
so he
accidentally rubs the ring and to his
surprise out pops a
gin or genie aladdin returns home to his
mother with a magical ring
a gin and a wonderful lamp his mother
decides maybe they should sell the lamp
in order to afford food
and as she begins wiping it down out
pops
a second gin much more powerful than the
first
with help from this jinn aladdin becomes
extremely rich
and marries the sultan's daughter
hearing of aladdin's
meteoric rise mustafa makes his return
knowing only the lamp could have caused
this much good fortune
he tricks aladdin's wife into giving him
the lamp
and his first command or wish is to take
the palace and
everything inside of it back to his home
when aladdin returns he does the only
thing he can
he summons the first genie from the ring
he tells aladdin that he cannot undo the
magic of the second gin but he can send
him to the palace
once there he kills mustafa and returns
his palace to its rightful place
this isn't how the story ends though
mustafa's older brother vows to avenge
his death
he transforms himself into an elderly
woman and owns his way
inside of aladdin's palace by convincing
his wife he has
magical powers the jin in the lamp
however sees through this disguise and
alerts aladdin of the imposter
who is then killed now we get the happy
ending
where aladdin eventually becomes sultan
and lives a
happy evil sorcerer-free life
when it comes to modern fiction jin and
genie have been interpreted in a variety
of ways
some are indeed lesser gods and others
are magical entities summoned through
the use of dark magic and witchcraft
one trope that is certainly stuck is
being granted three wishes when you
summon a genie
now these wishes have a habit of going
sideways and i'm sure
fans of the wish master franchise will
be more than familiar with a tricky gin
the jinn have appeared in stories for
thousands of years
and it's always interesting to see ideas
from different cultures
merge together and create new stories
whether it's a race of invisible spirits
at war
entities that live underground and
punish humans
a boy in his magical lamp or just
classic robin williams
you can't really go wrong with a story
of a gin
unless you're the one making the three
wishes
because in that case i wish you the best
of luck
as always i've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
you